child actors don't disappear in kids
movies plenty of actors and their teens
and younger have been in films of
gruesome imagery or disturbing subject
matter and even if the filmmakers tried
to Shield them from seeing too much it
surely had an effect the first thing 12
year old Tim does in River's Edge is
throw his sister's doll into a river
it's a mean-spirited act but it purpley
underscores the world of view of the
small town teams and director Tim
Hunter's 1986 film their alienation
manifests in ways from theft and drug
use to cold-blooded killing Tim is the
youngest of the film's characters but
also the most casually immoral by the
end Tim threatens to kill his own
brother
action of hit me
don't be stupid Tim
Joshua John Miller the son of playwright
and actor Jason Miller was just 12 years
old when he replaced Corey Haim as Tim
in River's Edge and with only a handful
of minor TV credits to his name but he's
totally convincing in carrying out Tim's
list of cruelties which includes
stealing drug dealer fixed gun and later
assaulting him with her Miller would
play other kids on the edge most notably
in near dark before transitioning to his
current career as a writer and TV
producer but none Were Us chilling as
Tim
the catalog of cruelties perpetrated by
Lena klammer a psychotic 33 year old
posing as an adolescent girl isn't the
most shocking element of 2009's orphan
Lena kills multiple people threatens
other children and attempts to seduce
her adoptive father but the really
disturbing aspect of these incidents is
that actress Isabella Furman was only 12
years old when the movie was made yet
Furman was more than happy to explore
the growing aspects of a character and
she told the Boston Herald in 2009 if
America hates me I've done my job Furman
doubled down on her astonishing
performance and orphaned first kill the
prequel released nine years after the
previous film though 25 at the time
Thurman gave another chillingly
believable turn as a nine-year-old Lena
with the help of body doubles Four's
perspective and make up special effects
but no CGI director William Brent Bell
told Showbiz cheat sheet sometimes I
think the visual effects components of
digital effects actually makes it look
worse in 13 Tracy Freeland played by
Evan Rachel Wood is already close to
emotional Ground Zero when she ends as a
seventh grade her divorce mum Melanie is
a recovering alcoholic and her body
image problems of led to self-harming
when she meets popular girl Evie played
by co-writer Nikki Reed her need for
acceptance pushes her into rash Acts
including shoplifting drug use and
casual sex that spiral into
self-destructive Behavior unfortunately
Tracy has only her fought relationship
with her mother as a support system
director Catherine Hardwick and Reed who
later collaborated on the Twilight
franchise Drew on Reed's own experiences
when writing 13. although Reed later
admitted that she exaggerated some of
her experiences in the script the
anxiety and confusion of being a teen
girl Rings true in much of the film
wouldn't read who was 16 and 15
respectively at the time of filming was
strictly monitored by hard work their
own mothers and a child welfare worker
joined their most difficult scenes to
ensure their emotional well-being in a
2015 interview at the late anneh and had
the Duffy for their podcast better
together with Anne and Heather actress
Mariel Hemingway said audiences would
never see her oscar-nominated breakout
role in Woody Allen's 1979 comedy
Manhattan if the movie was released in
the current film market and I'm
just a romantic relationship between a
42 year old writer played by Alan and
Hemingway's 17 year old student well
that scenario might have been offbeat
but acceptable in 1979 today it reads as
an older man's creepy manipulation of a
young girl another reason is the
accusations by Alan's adoptive daughter
Dylan Farrow who Elijah he sexually
abused her when she was just seven years
old it's very difficult to keep that out
of mind while watching Alan canoodle
with the teenage Hemingway but even the
most forgiving viewer must know that the
cultural landscape has changed and
that's an adult with a teenager under 18
is inappropriate fenfertiles have been a
Hollywood Trope since the days of silent
films but the stereotype takes an
exploitative turn when the dangerous
woman in question is a teenager the 1992
movie poison ivy aims for a cross
between film Noir and Fatal Attraction
and a story of a sexually free but
homicidally inclined teen the casting of
Drew Barrymore then in her career
rebound after struggles of drug
addiction and name players like Sarah
Gilbert and Tom Skerritt it's attempted
to lend respectability to the sleazy
role Barrymore than 17 isn't
particularly convincing at depicting Ivy
a deranged teen so taken with Gilbert's
normal life that she's willing to seduce
her father and kill her mother the
character is aware of her desirability
first unable to use it for anything
except base interests Barrymore gaming
handles the story's most brilliant
aspects which include making out with
the 17 year old Gilbert and 60 year old
skeret and pushing Chevrolet off a
balcony
the 1998 film adaptation of Stephen
King's Novella after pupil differs from
its source material but the film retains
this disturbing portrait of Evil's
corrupting influence the late Brad
Renfro stars as Todd a teenager who
discovers that his elderly neighbor Kurt
dusander played by Ian McKellen is a
former Nazi the team blackmails usander
into telling Chrisley's stories from
concentration camps their relationship
warps both men in dangerous ways Todd
blackmails his guidance counselor while
Kurt starts killing transience for those
some of the grizzlier elements of King's
Story are toned down for the movie many
are featured in Brandon Boyce's script
for Renfro who was 17 years old during
production that meant participating in
scenes where Todd helped kill a homeless
man and a fantasy sequence in which he
envisions his classmates as
concentration camp prisoners which
prompted a lawsuit against director
Brian Singer for inflation of emotional
distress and other charges Todd's
corrupted innocence was familiar to
Renfro throughout his acting career in
films including the client and
tragically in his own life of camera
which ended with his 2008 death from a
drug overdose at the age of 25. that's a
car alarm was just 11 years old when he
was casting check director barclav
Mahal's 2019 adaptation Jersey
kaczynski's novel The Painted bird he
couldn't have picked a more harrowing
story for his debut the movie follows a
mostly silent boy wandering through a
surreal hellscape in Eastern Europe
during the early days of World War II
the boy is brutalized beaten sexually
assaulted and tortured and witnessed his
horrific Behavior by every adult he
meets Carla had never acted on the film
before but holds his own and scenes
opposite Stalin Skarsgard Harvey Keitel
and the late Julian Sands in an
interview with the guardian Mahal said
he shielded Carla from the most
traumatizing scenes by capturing his
reactions separately from the action he
also relied on Carlisle's family and a
full-time assistant to provide him with
emotional support when it was needed
despite their protection The Experience
seems to have impacted kotler Mahal said
after he told me he doesn't want to be
an actor Alicia Silverstone made a big
screen debut in the crush a supremely
icky Thriller that casts a 17 year old
actress has a 14 year old lethal Lolita
with designs on a 28 year old journalist
played by Carrie elwells the film
directed by TV vet Alan Shapiro plays on
familiar sexist tropes about teenage
girls and the clueless adult men who
fall for them I'll always be your friend
no matter what okay
okay
like that night up to the lighthouse
when we kissed
Elway's character steps into every snare
laid by Silverstone and then experiences
a moment of Crisis about her age which
is supposed to generate sympathy when
she unleashes a torment of psychotic
behavior on him the crush portrays
silver Studios a contemptible object
while also fetishizing her sexuality as
the film's village is given all sorts of
outlandish schemes to carry out she
nearly kills elwez's new girlfriend and
pins a charge of sexual assault on him
at the same time the film also affirms
that it's okay to enjoy the camera
ogling a supposed 14 year old at every
turn the Washington Post reviews summed
up the films have it both ways approach
by noting there's something scuzzy about
the whole exercise Guillermo del Toro is
a passionate advocate of writer director
Issa Lopez's 2017 Mexican film tigers
are not afraid which is both a haunting
Supernatural Thriller and The Melancholy
look at the impact of drug violence but
as with deltaro's films like the Devil's
Backbone and Pan's Labyrinth tigers are
not afraid it's also about the
terrorists and traumas of childhood and
how some children learn to survive them
While others do not to deliver that gut
punch Lopez worked with an extraordinary
group of young actors and put them
through an emotional workout though it
was carefully guided the young actors
and tigers are not afraid to play
residents of an unnamed Mexican city
ravaged by drug lords the children lose
virtually everything parents homes even
mementos and death is around them at all
times bodies line the streets adults and
children are killed violently in front
of them and children are forced to fight
and even kill in return ghosts are also
a constant presence
urging revenge for their deaths
director's got derrickson's Thriller the
black phone is so briskly paced that
viewers might almost miss the storylines
truly horrible elements an adaptation of
a short story by Joe Hill the film
focuses on Finney played by Mason Thames
a teenager who has been abducted by
child murderer known as the grabber
though terrified Finney begins to
receive visions and messages from the
Grabbers to cease victims and formulates
an Escape Plan
Philly's communication with the victims
is so otherworldly that it's almost easy
to forget these kids have died in
particularly tragic ways they were
stolen off the streets of their
hometowns and tormented by a sadistic
Mass killer who eventually took their
lives in a way that endows Elite really
hurts as the Grabber puts it the
unendurable sadness of Finney's fate and
their deaths is fell to the emotional
line readings by fames he was 14 when
the film was released in 2021 and his
young castmates
in 2015's good night mummy a woman
returns to her isolated home after
surgery where twin Sons greet her at
least they believe she's her mother but
her angry often violent reactions to
them cause her voice to suspect
otherwise they hold her captive in
increasingly cruel ways to extract a
confession from her but what they
eventually discover is far more
complicated and chilling than a simple
imposter situation adding considerably
to the creepiness of this Austrian film
is that two young boys play the twins
Elias and Lucas Schwartz who according
to various sources were 12 while filming
carry out many unsettling acts they
raise huge cockroaches and look after a
dead cat and eventually tie down and
seal their alleged mother's mouth shut
to prevent her from screaming for help
when she refuses to change her story The
Boys glue her to the floor and said the
house Ablaze by that point it's far too
late for anyone to change their story
Michael hanaki's 1997 film funny games
as a polarizing experience you're either
wowed by the movies deliberate
manipulation to produce maximum horror
or completely disgusted by its catalog
of sadism the brutality to strangers
bring upon an Austrian family is painful
to watch and the torment seems of no
point Beyond amusing the culprits the
family's son Shoshi suffers some of the
worst abuse not only does he witness his
parents torture but he also stumbles
upon the corpse of his neighbor's
daughter in an attempt to flee the boy
who played by German Actor Stephen
klapchinsky who's only 11 at the time of
filming is also featured in one of the
film's most infamous scenes when he's
mercilessly shot by one of the strangers
the on-screen death of a child is
upsetting for audiences but when
accompanied by so much other awful
behavior is an almost unbearable
experience
foreign